guys will wander guys eyes will move in
different directions that's just
something that that a lot of women tend
to struggle with right like they think
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander because I'm with you then you
shouldn't be with anybody else but men
and women have different sexual
strategies how many times can you get
pregnant in one year D once right one
how many times can a guy impregnate
women in one year probably
365 times hundreds of times so you know
men and women have different sexual
strategies again setting aside the
morality I'm not saying it's right or
wrong that doesn't matter the fact
remains that women go outside of
relationships and so do men they do it
for different reasons and some people
have found ways to make it work where
it's just you know there's actually a
very interesting scene in a um in the
crown which is a uh series on the uh
Sovereign
Queen Elizabeth and she just died and I
saw this trending on Netflix the other
day and it reminded me there was a scene
where um Prince Philip was uh being
interrogated by the queen and she
essentially said the exact same thing
that we talked about earlier she said
look as long as you're
in the family
you're involved with the family and
you're doing your duties and roles I'll
just look the other way just don't
embarrass me basically is what she said
in that scene and that's really what it
seems to boil down to
um there's another good scene in the
movie since we're talking about stuff
have you seen Vikings
yes so when
Ragnar went away and then he had some
fun with that I can't remember her name
that uh tall Queen and then she showed
up in his village with his baby that's
when lagatha lost it right and then she
laughed that's what women don't want
they don't want that surprise they don't
want some random woman showing up
because what ends up happening is what
concerns you resources money love
they're like women don't want to share
those things right they're they're less
likely to share resources love and
attention of a guy but more likely to
share him sexually as long as he doesn't
bring back problems with that yeah you
see what I'm saying but they but then
they try to control that part too so
that it
limits the potential you know propensity
for those problems to arise because if
you because if you police wear his
penises at all times it's never going to
happen but it's like he'll just be more
sneaky about it
well that's that's one way that some
guys go about it too right so it is what
it is we drew a lot of inspiration from
um Marco Polo actually how that Dynamic
worked uh you watch Marco Polo no
watch it it's great uh
the um
the wife shabby how she holds herself
um
was very admirable to me because
obviously um
oh my God I forgot the main character's
name not Michael the the guy she married
I can't believe I forgot his name right
now
but um he obviously had his little
Mistresses living on the grounds and
she she picked them
and how is this for him yeah yeah there
was a thorough uh
process for that it's it's it's not that
uncommon I mean you know it's it's only
uncommon today whereas in the past like
the most successful men with influence
reach resources would often have a harem
of women but at no time in history did
women ever have a harem of men
um it just didn't exist I mean like many
people would argue that that would be
disgusting in fact but it's but it's
widely accepted that again high value
you know successful men have the
capacity to exercise those options and
some of them do some of them don't I
mean a lot of women like to
um berate and antagonize uh loyal men
and uh loyal high-value men and they're
the ones that really need to check
themselves because those guys are
um you know the good guys so
look folks it's a reality of Life uh D
sounds like she's got it sorted out and
there's no longer an issue and I'm glad
to hear that
um you know my concern again was for the
kid
um but um yeah it sounds like you guys
have it sorted out yeah I think we do I
think we do and I really appreciate you
responding to my email and offering me
this opportunity to speak to you and
um kind of agreeing with how everything
is going and giving me maybe the green
light but oh you're to give look I mean
like you guys gave yourselves a green
light to continue because this is
something that that may have destroyed
or torn apart another couple that might
have disadvantaged a child and uh it
sounds to me like you guys chose to sort
it out and do the right thing for both
you and it's working it's uncommon but
it's working so that's good so this is
just proof that you know things like
this can't work
yeah
so maybe I'll give you enough
I wish you guys all the best uh you know
you and your husband and you know with
your business everything you guys are
doing
um
let me just before you go let me just
see if there's any questions here if you
guys want to drop some questions in the
chat I'll you know I'll pose them since
I've got her on
um there's one here I'm curious as to
whether or not she feels an element of
arousal no one other women Pine for her
men
women do prefer men women do prefer men
that uh other women want and other men
want to be there's no question about it
the vast majority of women though in
especially in North American culture
don't want him to exercise those options
yeah I I would say that
what are our family and friends say
about it they don't know anything about
it okay
what do you think it would say if they
found out
um
the only I have a friend
um
and I did tell her about the condom I
found
what did she say what was the advice
that she gave you
she
um I I tried putting on some red pill
videos
uh she she couldn't really go with it
but she knew I was coming from with it
and she thought that
she had a lot of questions and
I I just said look I don't know
um but it's okay
and she's like so you didn't ask in this
you didn't ask if it's all these
questions I said well I I did actually
try and ask some questions because sort
of questions did she want you to ask him
just like um
you know where did they go who who was
it
um
how often did he see her
um are you sure that she didn't come
inside the home
um I found out that he done it in the
car and um
she had a lot of questions that's
interesting because all of those
questions are how many times did he see
her where did he take her
you know it's like quite it's not about
the intimacy act it's about what did he
do with her leading up to the intimacy
act that resulted in the condom right
yeah yeah interesting
um she she was fine with it um well I
mean not fine with it but
she was
very inspired by how I was dealing with
the situation because I actually didn't
tell her until about two months after
the fact I really needed to process it
on my own and not get influenced by
anybody else and
she was very shocked and she was just
like so you guys are okay everything's
okay with people and I was like yeah
we're good it's behind me now
what uh brought the both of you as a
pair to the red pill
oh I think it was Kevin Samuels with a
mixture of you with a mixture of
fashion fit I don't know I think these
things just started coming up on YouTube
and uh they were entertaining and we
decided we both read your book loved it
by the way and just really indulged in
this in this content because
uh
it's something we both enjoy and I agree
with pretty much everything that is said
and so it's fun for us both to watch
these things and just be in
on how most modern women
says uh well she put her trust in him
after the conundrum ends so does he does
he have 100 of your full trust right now
yeah
good yeah what what would he have to do
to break your trust
if any of the things that I requested or
that he knows that I don't want came to
surface so if the girl I don't know
maybe screenshots some messages and
sends them to me and
um I was trying to get involved in some
way to sabotage
um that would say to me that he maybe
chose a poor
um character of a woman there who play
with
uh yeah I mean trying to contact me
uh
does he does he tell them that they're
married
yeah yeah they all know the situation
between okay so it just says you know
I'm married my wife's gonna look the
other way but uh you know yeah she just
she just doesn't want to know the
details yep that's it okay yeah that's
exactly what it is all right uh so
uh menshine's asking why no emojis on
instagram conversations and I think we
covered that earlier it sounded like it
was because it's it's too close to
intimacy it's too close to love it's too
close to uh gaming her it's not about
the act of of of sex it's about the act
of like the game that leads up to it is
that is that a fair assessment yeah
so is he let's use the um emojis and
gifts or is that off the table
emojis and gifts
uh no you're keeping that off the table
I said it back then but
I don't care anymore yeah really
yeah but I would suggest keeping the
rules as simple as possible pick pick
two or three the ones that matter the
most
and uh I think you'll probably find uh
you know by the sounds of things he
probably won't even exercise these
options very often it's it's just
something that he needed to do and maybe
now that he's got the freedom to do it
you may not even exercise it that often
right maybe maybe when I actually um
found the message
um I asked him like what's going on here
and he's like I just want to talk for
the girl and I was like come on I don't
want to talk to other girls
what's really going on here and then we
got down to it it all happened in the
car like he left his he left the car and
that his phone was just there and I
thought now now is the time for me to
check it you came back to the car and he
just seen like my face
and my heart my whole body language and
he was like what is wrong I said what is
this
um we got into it all the about 30
minutes just been in the car talking
about it and
that was it we just I try and get all
the things I try not to hold grudges and
I really just try and move on and
there's an old saying that if you go
looking for dirt then you're gonna find
it right so if you want to
upset yourself you're gonna find ways to
connect dots to piss yourself off right
yeah
um Ernesto in the chat says that this
become a bigger issue once you got
pregnant
uh when I found the Instagram messages I
was already pregnant
mm-hmm uh when I found a condom way back
when I wasn't pregnant but I had
forgotten about it like it's over it
wasn't a problem
do you fear that he'll find somebody
younger
no
I mean you can but I don't have that's
not a fear of mine
uh uh how is the communication between
you two right now
very good
he just came home actually everything is
great that's excellent yeah really
really good all right well I'm going to
leave you to your evening hope you guys
enjoy it thanks for uh sending the email
and popping in and sharing your story
and your experience I think this is uh
insightful to many people watching
um there's some good questions that came
up there I'll take some questions from
you guys if you guys want to call in you
know with a standard q a uh D I'll let
you go have yourself a good night okay
thank you so much Richard all right take
care all right thank you
bye hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out